[Applause]
into the largest military base
around all right in this operations and
L of flood the resistance fires more
than 5,000
Rockets wait for
it reaching Aviv you hear that reaching
T reaching Tel Aviv okay in in in in a
conflict uh let's say you're you're a
you're you're in a prison they say it's
an open air prison you're locked up and
you're like it is unjust I was put here
against my will and my parents were here
and so you decide to start bombing the
town next door with a bunch of civilians
who live nearby I I just you're not
breaking out you're not it's it's like a
Sally out kind of if you're in a if
you're in a Siege situation and you're
the one that's under siege sometimes
they'll Sally out and try and cause
havoc in the enemy camp the enemy Siege
camp and then come back and and kill as
much and Destroy as much as they can
that's kind of what this was